as the 31st of October deadline for the
UK's withdrawal from the European Union
approaches MEP s will discuss the UK
government's position the implications
of a No Deal brexit and the conditions
under which Parliament would support a
third extension of article 50 MEP s will
vote on the nominee to head the European
Central Bank from the 1st of November
Christine Lagarde told Parliament's
Monetary Affairs Committee that under
her watch the ECB would become more
transparent and accessible to citizens a
year ago extreme weather and flooding
devastated parts of Europe landslides as
well as damage to forests and
infrastructure hits Romania Italy and
Austria the hardest MEP s will discuss
providing those countries with
assistance via the European solidarity
fund 2020 budget negotiations are set to
start in earnest with the council
representing EU countries setting out
its position on what the Commission has
proposed tens of thousands of fires have
been raging for weeks in the Amazon
rainforest the lungs of our planet more
than 900,000 hectares of forest have
been destroyed this year alone MEP s
will debate the implications of the
fires and what Europe should do